here's a question did you hate science
in high school well even if you did we
think you'll still want to listen to
titi show daya and Zakia Watley their
new bimonthly podcasts on Spotify it's
called dope labs uses humor and social
media to start conversations about the
science in our everyday lives and they
say there is science in our everyday
lives CTM national correspondent Jericka
Duncan met Satya and Watley in Brooklyn
recently and joins us to discuss dareka
good morning dude good morning to you
these two met while studying for their
PhDs at Duke University Watley and
biology and Shadia and engineering they
both say they want their podcasts to
make sure that science is more
accessible for everyone who is this
podcast for I would like to say that
this podcast is for everybody it's
intentionally designed for people who
are most often left out from science
right and from the scientific narratives
like women people of color we try to
Center what's going on in those
communities so we are on Instagram
Twitter we're saying what are people
talking about I'm TT and I'm Sofia and
we are best friends and two of the
dopest scientists that you will ever
meet can we ask you a couple of
questions we're doing episode about
genetic testing TT show dia and zakiya
Watley say they're sho dope Labs is not
your typical science podcast that's
because they are not your typical
scientists we feel like we're the people
scientists because we are one of the
people their goal is to make science
more inclusive and relatable by covering
a wide range of subjects this episode
we're talking about vaccines we want to
talk about the stars in our sky we are
talking about what Conda
specifically vibranium we're also gonna
talk about bad blood what does it mean
big bone really all the signs you really
care about we're bringing it to you
you're not talking like a scientist
that's intentional right something we
know is that we're qualified right we
both have PhDs and so there's no need
for me to perform for academia the
people we want to engage are the people
that are outside of the scientific space
our voices in this space are very
important because there aren't very many
voices that that are like ours when you
think of the most famous black female
scientist that's in the mainstream media
who is that it's doc McStuffins and so
we want to kind of break the mold a
little bit and what people usually hear
and when they're consuming science you
share roughly 99.98%
of your DNA with other everybody else
that means I share about 99.9% my DNA
with what's the biggest compliment
you've received that makes you feel like
your message is doing exactly what you
wanted it to do when folks say I never
listen to podcasts but I listen to your
podcast that's what I say we are really
doing something really really special
here at dope labs we believe that
science is for everybody and our mission
is to bring out the inner scientist in
you what does that look like for you all
now as young women not just doing a
podcast but sort of being ambassadors of
science for young people you don't have
to be this stereotype of what you feel
like a scientist is and that usually is
a real eye-opener for them when we get
introduced as Doctor zakiya Watley dr.
titi sheedia and they're like what her I
think one of the most powerful things we
can do is just show up yes right and so
I think if we show up in these spaces as
ourselves I think that sends the message
right there right that you can look like
us
and be a scientist you can look like us
and be anything you want to be showing
up dope labs launched through Spotify
sound up contest a program that aims to
increase diversity in the podcasting
landscape by supporting shows hosted by
women of color they were great that's my
kind of science show they said we all
have an inner scientist we just need to
figure where is it I don't know the
error body all right